All right. Let's get serious now.
We need to move to using a real task
to fetch the weather.
After all, weather is serious business.
Let's create a separate FetchWeatherTask
to populate our content provider database.
And we'll start by moving our existing task
over to this new one.
Wow. It's good to get that big task
out of ForecastFragment.
And we're going to change the parameters
to string void, void.
Oh, we've got a lot of compile errors to fix.
That's okay.
For now, we're going
to delete everything except for
the do in background part
of the AsyncTask.
Let's give it a constructor
and pass in a context.
(keyboard clicking)
In doing background,
let's save off the locationQuery
as a string to make the code
easier to understand.
And for fun, let's fetch the maximum
14 days of forecast data.
Since we temporarily deleted
getWeatherDataFromJson,
we can remove from the try catch
at the bottom.
We're going to look for lots of additional data
from the openweather API.
To make this easy,
here are the strings we'll use.
We'll also get the city name,
the latitude and longitude
returned by OpenWeather.
Now, we do have to wrap this in a try
in order to make sure
that we handle the exception.
All right. Now we've handled the exceptions,
so everything compiles.
And, hey, look, we've
got the city name and coordinates.
Hmm, we've now gotten the location
that we can use to insert things
into the database.
And we haven't done this in a while,
so it's time for a programming exercise
but before we can do that let's actually
make sure that your app
can really compile.
Let's go back to ForecastFragment,
and take a look at how
FetchWeatherTask is working.
One is that FetchWeatherTask
is going to require
that we get an activity
or some other context,
and pass that in there.
Another thing we can do
is remove these pesky shared preferences.
And there we have it.
A utility function that gets us
our preferred location.
All right, so now, we're ready
to run the applications
we can actually do the next exercise.
Once again, we're going to be calling
into our very new fetch weather task,
but it's not going to do anything
other than try and read some JSON.
So we've got to make it
do something beyond that.